today's question
comes from doreen in montana she visited
daveramsey.com
to ask i was wondering once baby step 2
is completed is the plan to save only
for an emergency fund
i want to also have some savings in the
anticipation of a non-emergency
non-emergency items such as vet bills
car repairs vacation home improvement
does all this come after the emergency
fund is complete
on a sort of save as you go basis yeah
so your emergency fund is going to be
definitely your next goal and then
everything else after that is what we
call syncing funds
so you'll have different funds that you
say i'm going to put a little bit of
money each month
into these funds and so when something
does come up you have a vet bill
car repair you just take it out of that
sinking fund
sinking funds are something we've we've
talked about for a while i feel like we
haven't done a ton of like
deep dives or i haven't teaching into
these but
they're really crucial and they're very
helpful to stay ahead because
when things do come up because they will
you actually have the cash there
you've been saving for it and instead of
even taking it out of an emergency fund
you have some extra cash on the side for
these yeah these
it's basically saying christmas this
year will be in december
and so you should plan for that yep save
a little bit money suicide for christmas
um now i personally would say you're
gonna
budget uh i mean you're gonna have money
in your budget
and if you have a reasonably small vet
bill you're just going to put that in
this month's budget
if you have a reasonably small car
repair you're going to put that in this
much budget
if you have a 3 000 vet bill or a 3 000
car repair that comes out of the
emergency fund
that's an emergency if your transmission
goes out that's an emergency
that's not a you don't need a separate
sinking fund to get ready for some day
your transmission going
so unless you're in a some kind of
extreme situation with pets
you should cash flow 98
of vet bills out of your monthly budget
as they come up now i'll say winston i
we have a line item in our budget for
gas
and repairs and whatever money is not we
don't spend on gas or repairs kind of
floats over to the next month so we just
kind of keep it going it's not a bad
idea on car repairs
that does build up that way it becomes a
little savings account for that's kind
of our car repair is how we do it
but you how do you pay for tires that
are a thousand bucks exactly but i will
say with this you're not having a
you're not having separate savings
accounts for each of these little things
no no no
no so you have to be pretty diligent to
say okay no we've had this amount of
money
in our account that we see that
percentage goes to this this this you
have to be on top of it because it's
easily you can
you know you just start to pile up some
money and then suddenly it starts to
just
disappear because you're spending it so
you do have to be diligent with those
sinking funds yeah but you know let's
say you got two
three kids okay you don't have to have a
line item for the pediatrician
right uh you can just cover that when it
comes up yes and you don't need a
sinking fund for that
right either one if it came up and it
was a big problem
medically with a child it would be an
emergency out of the emergency fund
fair and so that you know your fur
babies would be the same thing right
you know so um we've both got dogs and
we don't have sinking funds for the dogs